if you've been wishing cgj drum roll
through bleacher for you wish came true
we got drum with it's going on man
what's up my bro july twenty second yeah
quality street music too yes we're gonna
get to that in a little bit about that
you need to set the record straight for
us already a in the rap game okay i'm
gonna give you a player I you tell me
which artist you that reminds you up
okay cool so let's start over brawn um I
think arguably unfairly enough I LeBron
is Drake we're on a string why why would
you say that he's the most dominant
player in the NBA right now you know
he's proven he's got his ranks he's had
his moments when he's been most hated
went for most love to most hated the
most loved again sure you're not i mean
and um he can pretty much play every
position that's a surface level
breakdown you got deep in their stuff
you say he's most dominant player in the
game but he wasn't the unanimous MVP
that would be step right which artist
Kendrick Lamar Kendrick Lamar I mean I'm
interested there's always that back and
forth there has been this last year
about what both guys have done for their
team for the league Steph was clearly
the MVP you know he went he made history
this year but then he lost in in the in
the finals yeah uh he's the darling of
the industry in so many ways but yet
when he steps on that court he's still
fear by you know the other athletes what
about stephs new teammate KD given the
move he just made is there anybody who's
made a move in hip-hop that you could
say is similar Katie Katie could be like
a cake let's meet very very dominating
streets love him mmm you know put in
some work you know regardless of the the
moment when he made his decision people
still want to see what's going to happen
with Katie let's do something different
somebody who just stepped out of the
limelight in the NBA kobe bryant but on
all-time great Colby you know i like to
say like kobe is is little Wayne you
know if LeBron is Drake Kobe's little
Wayne and in Jordan's jay-z okay I Kobe
you know is arguably
is down one of the best players ever do
it with Lil Wayne same thing you know
best rapper alive yeah let's go down to
Atlanta okay Dwight Howard when I was
like soulja boy it's very vocal and you
know got some you know all court
off-court things going on yeah DJ Drama
aka mr thanksgiving AKA Barack Oh drama
nobody's got a Rolodex a nickname drama
like this man Tom Cruise uh the list
goes on Judith us appreciate a bit love